[Musique]
à
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports le rendez vous qu'il ne
faut absolument pas manquer si vous êtes
un amoureux du sport local pour
m'accompagner aujourd'hui quatre
chroniqueurs la crème de la crème du
département sont autour de cette table
et non pas en vacances présentation en
musique on commence à ma droite il est
l'un des meilleurs cyclistes du
département dans la catégorie masters ce
tout roule pour lui en ce moment il est
arrivé dans le studio avec un large
sourire comme d'habitude le capitaine
rial dujarrier est avec nous vincent
mutel
quand allez vous fatigué fatigué vous
avez toujours oui cela n'empêche pas
l'autre un c'est pas vrai c'est pas
parce que physiquement c'est difficile
en ce moment que plus le moral n'est pas
bon et que souligne un vous auriez pu
être en vacances et vous êtes ici sur le
plateau avec moi je ne sais pas ce que
c'est le mot vacances on passe de
l'autre côté musique c'est aujourd'hui
une incontournable de cette émission pas
besoin d'attendre l'été pour apercevoir
un rayon de soleil ici dans le studio
nous l'avons avec nous à chaque
enregistrement avec notre ambassadrice
de charme
hélène de la grange qui nous vient tout
droit de versailles je suis ravi de
revenir encore commence à jouer elle est
bien très bien j'ai fait ma petite
chasse aux oeufs j'ai mangé du chocolat
dont je suis en forme
on vous attend un enfant en tout cas si
on passe de l'autre côté musique il fait
son grand retour dans cette émission
c'est un homme d'expérience qui a vu de
nombreuses montées et de nombreuses
descentes avec son club et vous pouvez
vous retourner et aujourd'hui lui aussi
a le sourire car son club monte en
fédérale 3 olivier naveau 9 président a
délégué du rugby-club de versailles nous
fait l'honneur de revenir dans ce talk
comment allez-vous lui grand plaisir
présent par délégation est au service du
collectif
forfait on passe de l'autre côté
mesdames et messieurs je demande le
silence sur ce plateau son retour était
plus attendue que l'ultime saison de
game of thrones vous reconnaissez
forcément sa musique c'est une montagne
de cette émission il n'a jamais sa
langue dans sa poche
genlis ex-entraîneur de plaisir et sur
ce plateau est aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau
bonjour à tous et à toutes que vous
allez vous toujours en forme j'ai fait
pas qu'un donc voilà game of thrones
savoure jouer avec mes oeufs
gamehope alors je suis partie de ceux
que l'ont pas vu un seul épisode lui un
déclic j'ai mes goûts regard ici on
parler sport par contre dans la parole
ça tombe bien parce qu'on va continuer à
parler de sport avant de passer au
programme d'émission a parlé de cyclisme
dimanche 21 avril 10h près de 100
coureurs venus de toute la france se
sont déplacés pour participer à la
troisième édition du grand prix de
montigny le bretonneux dans les rues de
la commune
les coureurs de d1 et d2 se sont élancés
sur un circuit de 3 km fermée à la
circulation
les sportifs ont dû réaliser vingt six
tours et à une moyenne de plus de 35 km
heure après 78 km de course et
finalement romain barras qui a remporté
en solitaire le grand prix à voir après
avoir distancé ses concurrents dans les
derniers tours on écoute ses réactions
ça fait toujours plaisir en y avait du
monde je sais qu'il y avait des bons
coureurs donc voilà fallait fallait
partir avec le avec le bon groupe et
et puis bang gestion se fait toujours
plaisir c'est je sais qu'il y avait du
niveau c'est assez relevé donc de finir
premier c'est toujours satisfaction
est-ce que c'est à refaire vous votez
oui ou non
weepu raihani jarrier oui autour de
cette table on est tous convaincus gens
pour votre grand retour
vous êtes convaincu bien sûr plus il ya
de manifestations sportives
mieux c'est donc on peut pas s'auto bus
jacqueline quand même avoir et il ya
d'ailleurs pour avoir du monde là il
faut se mettre avec un extérieur du
vélodrome quoi finalement
parce que là y avait peu de monde donc
la vie sur les images des événements de
ce bord de route et pas mal de cyclistes
et puis une manifestation sportive comme
celle là il faisait beau toutes les
conditions étaient réunies
il faut multiplier ce genre de vermand
nigeria vous n'y étiez pas sur cette
compétition
non parce que ben c'est l'éruption sur
route et moi je ne cours plus que sur
piste depuis depuis quelques années
maintenant voilà c'est vrai que ces
catégories donc c'est départementale 1
et départementale 2 ça veut bien dire ce
que ça veut dire ce sont des coureurs
qui sont tous amateurs et qui devrait
pouvoir courir dans leur département
tous les week-ends et ce n'est pas le
cas parce que les animations coûtent
très cher parce que c'est très compliqué
pour d'avoir les autorisations
préfecture c'est vrai que ça embête pas
mal les riverains et quand on quand on
arrive à trouver des circuits pour pour
organiser on se retrouve très
régulièrement sur ce type de compétition
dans les zones industrielles si elles ne
sont pas occupés les week-ends mais ça
fait pas des parcours très intéressant
pour les pour les pratiquants donc donc
en effet je trouve ça il faut que ce
soit il faut qu'il faut que ce soit
reconduit fonctionner beaucoup beaucoup
plus souvent parce que justement ce type
de ces types de coureurs sont
doivent pouvoir courir proche de chez
eux sans avoir à traverser la région et
parfois alors là encore en ile de france
on est quand même très bien garni mais
dans beaucoup d'autres régions les gars
c'est des départs le matin pourquoi
recours à l'après midi et à revenir le
soir pour juste pouvoir assouvir sa
passion et c'est quand même c'est quand
même très compliqué et bien dommage
olivier c'est une course qui peut
prendre de l'ampleur robin certainement
moi je vais je suis nostalgique des
grands prix des semaines commerciales
dans le siècle précédent à versailles et
tous les ans il y avait la semaine
commerciale qui était venue de sow qui
bloquait tout et puis avait le grand
prix de la semaine commerciale des bons
alors c'était même ses grands prix de
traverser versailles fait tout est fermé
à la circulation s'était formé le cd
soirée dont je me souviens encore
aujourd'hui donc toutes sortes des
vêtements comme ça qu'ils peuvent mettre
en avant des cyclistes locaux et
régionaux
il faut le faire je comprends aussi que
c'est très compliqué incarne mr
d'organisation voilà parce que la route
était fermée un vraiment à la
circulation
et justement il pense peut-être déplacer
la date au mois de mars plutôt que
plutôt que pâques parce que nous pensons
que c'est une bonne solution
hélène parce qu'il ya un peu plus de
monde
oui après tant de spectateurs notamment
et en terme de participants c'est sûr
que oman air serait peut-être plus de
monde parce que voilà les vacances sont
quand même plus éloignées il n'y a pas
ce week-end de pâques etc
mais après est-ce que le temps sera au
rendez vous est ce que les gens
bougeront plus en mars tout dépend en
fait qu'en mars et début mars ça risque
d'être un peu
un peu quitte ou double en fait donc à
voir alors que le calendrier
chez les départementaux le mois de mars
est déjà va veut dire très bien fourni
mais il ya déjà pas mal gagné à des
compétitions sur lesquelles on a
l'habitude de se déplacer
je me souviens de la première à
[Musique]
fontainebleau kaki un circuit un circuit
formidable voilà on allait y en a des
courses de clamart aussi qui en zone
industrielle mais c'est le championnat
du monde des sprinteurs donc c'est une
course qui me tient à coeur mais donc
voilà on a des on est déjà doté de
course donc ils ont trouvé leur place au
mois deux mois d'avril pendant les fêtes
de pâques c'est pas grave faut continuer
et bien sûr que ça fera venir le monde
l'important c'est de trouver un beau
circuit sécurisé et ça c'est ça c'est
primordial pour revenir à versailles je
sais qu'ils avaient aussi la nocturne de
porchefontaine à une épanouie et la
nocturne de porchefontaine c'était une
très très grosse course au niveau
régional mais maintenant c'est plus
possible d'organiser en soirée la
nocturne c'était des compétitions qui
avait lieu entre verdi entre 18 et 20
heures
on finissait il faisait nuit voilà on
étire est emmené tirer la bourre entre
entre cyclistes et avait dit prime
c'était très très spectaculaire beaucoup
beaucoup de monde venez venez regarder
maintenant c'est fini c'est plus
possible quoi de pouvoir aider ce type
de compétition et au mois de mars
également il ya une toute petite
compétition vous avez oublié d'en parler
c'est le paris nice également dans les
yvelines
ces voix là cette progression serait
dommage de faire concurrence voit alors
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler football des jeunes est
vivement participé à la danone nations
cup la coupe du monde des jeunes à
clairefontaine nous ferons également un
coup de projecteur sur le futur centre
national de l'arbitrage qui devrait être
installé à poissy mais avant de
développer ces thèmes
on va parler rugby dans ce talk
[Musique]
on commence ce tour d'horizon de
l'actualité sportive part du rugby les
plaisirs aux as peuvent exulter ce
dimanche 21 avril les jaune et bleu ont
réussi à se maintenir lors de l'ultime
journée du championnat de fédérale 2
après une victoire 35 à 28 face au havre
à domicile on écoute les réactions micro
de notre journaliste nicolas landry très
content très heureux du contenu
de ce qu'ils ont fait les garçons
gros investissement gros combat et en
même temps on n'a pas oublié de notre
volume de jeu on n'a pas oublié de jouer
donc ça s'est très très bien
l'équipe termine finalement à la 9e
place du classement et jouera une
troisième saison consécutive dans ce
championnat de fédérale 2 le staff et
les joueurs retiendront avant tout la
progression de l'équipe cette saison
effectivement ils n'étaient pas là par
hasard qu'elle maintient qui avait eu
lieu l'année dernière c'était pas non
plus un hasard
et du coup on a vraiment travailler
positivement et on a pu faire progresser
encore une fois les gars sur ce qu'on
espère et sur ce qu'on aime voir sur un
terrain de rugby c'est à dire du jeu
quoi avant le début du championnat les
joueurs de plaisir voulaient viser une
sixième place finalement c'est raté mais
ils ont quand même le maintien la
question sur ce thème est-ce que la
saison de plaisir est réussi oui ou non
oui oui de thunes anime autour de cet
homme c'est réussi oui de toute façon
rien que le fait de se maintenir ou la
progression c'est toujours positif donc
après on peut clairement pas mettre un
petit rouge malgré la sixième place qui
n'a pas été attendri non genre dans les
choses a parlé pendant après 45 minutes
là pas du tout pas du tout je peux y
sommes non alors oui loge pour moi
plaisir réussi sa saison puisque le fait
de se maintenir pour la deuxième année
consécutive en fédérale 2 c'est une
performance après vous avez mis comme
objectif la sixième place ce qui est
normal parce qu'il faut toujours fixé un
objectif par rapport à la saison
dernière
c'est normal finalement c'était par
rapport à l'effectif qu'ils avaient ils
pas rapport aux 2 équipes qu'ils avaient
en face ces copies qui fait c'est
compliqué quand on la fédérale 2 ce gars
est difficile de se maintenir donc les
objectifs des nains dans les premières
saisons c'est vraiment d'y figurer et de
pouvoir prendre sa place pour prendre le
rythme et pouvoir après monter quelque
chose autour de ça donc là c'est la
deuxième saison ils vont attaquer leur
troisième saison je pense que à comparer
avec la première saison où ils étaient
où il était en fédérale 2
oula c'est ce que je disais un peu tout
à l'heure ils ont eu la chance cette
première saison et tant mieux pour eux
d'avoir d'hautmont et arras qui était
complètement à la rue comme et comme
équipe ça leur a permis de se maintenir
parce que sportivement il avait que 25
points de paiement et 25 points dans les
autres poules il serait descendu donc
ils se soient maintenus
la première saison par contre cette
saison celui-ci commun qu'ils ont acquis
leur maintien dans ce qu'ils ont réalisé
de belles performances sont battus
gennevilliers il avait accroché drancy
où je n'aime pas ce qu'ils n'ont pas
depuis trente six ans nous raccrocher
juste donc sportivement on voit une
évolution quand même on voit que le
groupe a pris le niveau fédérale 2 et
commencer maintenant a ajoué aller
titiller les grosses écuries co2 donc
sportivement ils ont réussi leur saison
et ils sont comme l'entraîneur l'a dit
en nette progression quoi ils sont en
constante progression on le voit on le
voit par rapport au résultat alors en
jeu au jeu je peux pas le dire parce que
j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu leurs matches
donc je peux pas me parler mais par
rapport à leur résultat et par rapport
aux équipes contre lesquelles ils ont
joué on voit une réelle progression et
et c'est pour cela que j'ai répondu oui
sur sur la saison réussie comme problème
oliveira vous êtes d'accord avec jean
absolument je pense qu'ils étaient dans
une poule avec des très gros budget de
club donc le budget de plaisir et
parfois assez mystérieux mais je suis
sûr qu'en tout cas il est beaucoup moins
élevé que 80 90 % des plus vielles de la
poule et ce qui est fait plaisir cette
année c'est surtout sa deuxième partie
de saison
en première partie de saison ça a été
compliqué mais ils ont redressé la barre
de façon incroyable dans la deuxième
partie de la saison en accrochant
pratiquement toutes les équipes et sur
place à plaisir ça devenait très
difficile de gagner et spécialement à
drancy ont failli battre nancy deux fois
donc ça c'est dansiez fini premiers de
poule sont battus or c'est dimanche
dernier pour finir premier de poule
puisque marcq en baroeul été finalement
disqualifié donc mais franchement je
pense que le niveau de l'eau si du jeu à
monter et que il s'installe
progressivement au niveau il lui est
donc peut-être qu'un et prochaine
alors après c'est aussi des ambitions de
de bitche et autres mais peut-être que
c'est la bonne
apparemment ce sont les joueurs qui fixe
l'objectif en début de saison des
joueurs ce contrat d'objectifs dans
l'adéquation bien sûr avec les idées du
staff mais j'espère aussi que fixer un
objectif parce que finalement quelque
part il faut qu'il y ait une
organisation autour des objectifs
ils se sont fait peur jusqu'à la
dernière journée ian est ce que
finalement la saison et ne s'estime pas
en demi teinte
finalement quand on joue le maintien on
joue le maintien jusqu'au bout ça se
décide rarement beaucoup plus tôt soit
on arrive à exploser le explosé
l'objectif et du coup on est tranquille
on est tranquille à mi saison parce que
on sent que la routine elle elle se joue
et c'est ce qui va se passer l'année
prochaine il risque d'être dans cette
routine qui va leur permettre s'ils
continuent sur la même femme de face il
arrive à enchaîner la fin 2-2 les
matches retour de la même manière que
pour l'année prochaine eh bien à garder
ce niveau de jeu ils vont pouvoir
justement se dire on oublie le maintien
va on va pouvoir essayer d'aller jouer
autre chose mais quand on joue le
maintien ça se finalise souvent sur la
dernière journée quoi là dessus oui bien
sûr que bien sûr que c'est un c'est un
stress pas mais on a senti flat dessus
mais non c'est un stress mais on en sort
grandi de toute façon parce que ça se
finit positivement donc pour moi non
c'est pas c'est pas grave et puis voilà
les experts du plateau nous disent
qu'ils ont quand même ils ont quand même
me des difficultés au premier de la
poule 1 c'est aussi des belles
satisfactions
maintenant comme disait aussi gens c'est
vrai que la progression peut peut-être
simplement aussi la notte en terme de
points qu'ils ont marqué la mairesse des
prix 25 points cette année ils sont à
combien de points
aujourd'hui on va regarder classement je
crois je crois que c'est de 45 points je
crois science qu'on va regarder
facilement s'il va se ficher beaucoup
beaucoup plus que l'année dernière
on n'a pas le classement n'a pas de
classement et 45 ans d'accord donc là il
autant l'année dernière c'est vrai
qu'ils auraient dû descendre et nous pas
ils ont pas eu cette descente là cette
année avec 45 points ils méritent ils
méritent de rester de rester en fédérale
2 y a un groupe qui est née cette saison
vraiment gens à votre avis enfin le
groupe pour connaître plus plaisir
le groupe il y est depuis un certain
temps qu il ya quand même une belle
ossature
il ya un groupe qui est qu'un ensemble
depuis quelques années et
après c'est toujours pareil c'est le
sais d expérience et d expériences avec
seulement 5 points
voilà c'est des expériences comme celle
là qui forcément forgent les groupes et
renforce renforcer l'amitié entre entre
les joueurs mais le groupe il y est
quand même le but qu'à quelques saisons
et un bon groupe
olivier vous êtes d'accord le plaisir
l'extérieur c'est toujours avec les
regards des communes comme une cédule
gauloise plein de résistance un atout
les new donc c'est une chapelle pour moi
c'est une chapelle comme ça s'il s'avère
que c'est un esprit de groupe qui est
bien particulier qui a une typologie
bien particulière moi je suis comme ça
que je le ressens en extérieur genre
bien sûr il a vécu avec ce groupe là
pendant deux ans tout ça donc il le
connaît bien mais je suis sûr que cela
quoi c'est des gens qui sont quand ils
sont soudés et aucun problème s'ils vont
à la guerre ils sont allés capable
d'aller jusqu'au bout 6e ou 9e ça change
quelque chose finalement rien du tout si
ce n'est que 6e et aurait pas eu il
n'aurait pas attendu si longtemps tenu
la dernière journée pour être sûr d'être
maintenue mais sinon six ou neuf c'est
un peu dans le dans le ventre mou c'est
surtout je vous dis seront là vu la 40e
point ça rien à voir avec la saison
dernière et donc ça reste quand même des
pets des belles perspectives pour la
saison prochaine parce que encore une
fois ils ont pris vraiment le rythme là
on le voit on le voit et c'est compliqué
pour les équipes qui jouent justement
comme le plaisir qui joue pas les
premiers
les premiers rôles de la poule parce que
tous les dimanches c'est la guerre
encore tous les dimanches il faut être à
100% pour essayer d'exister pour essayer
de survivre contrairement à une grosse
écurie où on peut faire tourner où on
peut faire reposer sur certains matches
certains joueurs là vous pouvez pas vous
êtes quasiment obligé quasiment de
mettre les meilleurs tout le temps parce
que vous avez besoin de résultats où
vous avez besoin de performer donc là
dans ce cas de figure
je crois qu'ils ont grandi ils sont bien
en fédérale 2 et c'est que des bonnes
choses pour la saison prochaine n'est
rien par rapport à ce que la question
vous me posiez est-ce que neuf points
cfa 9e ou 6e il ya une vraie différence
on voit qu'ils ne sont qu'à six points
de leurs visites de des deux départs qui
voient là est donc finalement c'est une
victoire bonifiée c'est un point
défensif qui a peut-être pas été pris à
un moment
un autre bon c'est sur une saison
complète de 22 matches bah c'est pas
grand chose quoi nous ils sont dans les
110 lits voilà qu'ils sont dans les
clous de détails
ils sont dans les clous c'est des petits
détails et voilà et et si la progression
continue n'y a pas de raison qu'il n'y a
pas de raison que ça s'arrête parce que
comme vous dites l'ambiance est là et
les gars jouent tous ensemble parce
qu'il ya une vraie une vraie osmose sur
plaisir l'année prochaine ça va ça va
ils vont après la dernière journée pour
se maintenir
oui et non mathématiquement on va dire
parce que quand même il fallait que la
barre a thief le havre
il fallait que le havre gagner à plaisir
avec le bonus offensif et en même temps
que le puck perdent chez eux contre
contre se le revers de leurs adversaires
du jour dans le havre celle là on était
venu est venu jouer à plaisir donc c'est
vrai que mathématiquement il n'était pas
encore maintenue mais il était car il
est quand même vachement un pied et demi
en cours en fédérale 2 mais à la
question sur cette thématique est ce que
plaisir peut viser plus haut finalement
on parler de budget tout à l'heure
olivier qui peuvent aller plus haut donc
lorsque l'esprit de guerre esprit de
groupe a ses limites quand même il faut
avoir aussi d'autres sources que ça et
donc il faut un moment qui est
possibilité d'avoir des budgets
je ne connais pas le budget de plaisir
donc mais il faut quand même je pense
qu'il ya une grosse différence est
obligé de marcq en baroeul et d'orsay
dans cette foule tarissant ils sont
marcq en baroeul crois que c'était au
dessus des millions d'autres équipes au
dessus du million d'euros et or c'est
bon alors c'est c'est 800 milles au
moins 900 mille donc alors comme voilà
ils ont le plus gros budget ils étaient
premiers invaincus et ils sont jaunes
sanctionné est prévu de est puni de
phase finale comme ça ça trompe un peu
le jeu on va passer maintenant notre
rubrique focus
[Musique]
on continue par du football une journée
exceptionnelle pour 1600 enfants les
jeunes footballeurs âgés de 10 à 12 ans
en plus jouer ce samedi 13 avril sur les
terrains d'entraînement de l'équipe de
france à clairefontaine à l'occasion de
la danone nations cup leurs coupes du
monde à eux
présentation de cet événement c'est une
vraie compétition qui existe donc depuis
plus de 20 ans elle est a été créée par
notre président après la coupe du monde
98 pour permettre aux enfants de
réaliser leur rêve le rêve étant de
pouvoir jouer comme les grands joueurs
de football sur des terrains connus lors
de cet événement n'a plus croisé des
jeunes de versailles de trappes de
poissy ou encore de guyancourt en écoute
les réactions c'est exceptionnel
puisqu'elle est déjà l'année dernière on
pouvait on a on n'est pas venu et ça
n'est pas c'est déjà bien d'être là
qu'on perde qu'on gagne au moins ces
plaisirs jouer à clairefontaine
un endroit qui est normalement réservé
uniquement à l'élite
toutes les équipes de france c'est une
expérience unique dont elles vont se
rappeler je pensais toute leur vie après
cette journée aucune équipe héninoise
n'est malheureusement parvenu à se
qualifier pour la grande finale
nationale qui se disputera le 22 juin
prochain à paris la question sur ce
thème cet événement peut-il donner envie
aux enfants de devenir professionnel non
pour yann dujarrier on va faire un petit
duel entre entre gens pour son grand
retour et yann viennent vous commencez
je vais non parce que tout le monde
allait dire oui je mets des bas voilà je
mets un peu d'un tout d un peu de débats
dans le dans le sujet j'y vais je vais
dire ouais je veux dire non parce que
pour moi ils font un sport où il ya
quand même très très peu d'élus et ça il
faut pas l'oublier et je pense que
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de gens
devraient elles devraient se l'entendre
dire parce que parce que c'est un sport
c'est un sport ou en effet ça brasse des
millions mais il faut savoir que tout en
bas de l'échelle ils sont aussi des
millions à vouloir y jouer et c'est très
facile et c'est très accessible de jouer
de jouer au football
donc là il était 1600 votre avenir est
un qui deviendront professionnels 1 ou 2
1 ou 2 oui enfin way et encore et encore
parce que en effet la y sont 1600 mais
ils sont ici sens et ça représente que 1
4 ou 1 aurait peut-être un quart de la
france vous avez quand même beaucoup de
clubs de beaucoup que 2 également il de
la région une autre étape dans le sud de
la france voilà donc ces belles c'est
essentiellement le sang c'est l'horreur
voilà donc et donc ça veut dire qu'il y
en encore 1600 qui sont ailleurs et va y
avoir une finale qui sera qui sera
déroulé au mois de juin donc maintenant
bien sûr que là dedans mais il y en aura
peut-être un ou deux qui vont qui vont
sortir et qu'ils deviendront des plus
des joueurs professionnels et ou alors
peut-être pas mais au moins qu'ils
accéderont la ligue 1 voilà parce que
professionnel maintenant on est aussi un
peu plus un peu plus bas dans les dents
les niveaux dans le niveau de foot du
football mais c'est vrai que non non
faut pas vendre du rêve faut pas vendre
du rêve à l'aube à nos gamins c'est le
sport de haut niveau c'est très très
difficile
c'est pas accessible à tous et et c'est
pas parce que techniquement on est très
très bon que mentalement on aura la
capacité de pouvoir se bouffer des
séances d'entraînement qui vont qui vont
vous détruire qui vont qui vont faire
très très mal et puis il faudra aussi
revenir après des blessures il va
falloir donc mentalement ces sportifs de
haut niveau s'est passé pas offert à
tout le monde et c'est vrai que le sage
il faut où il faut pouvoir en parler il
faut le dire beaucoup plus souvent genre
c'est à vous et moi j'ai dit oui et j'ai
dit oui parce que 10 12 ans si les
joueurs actuels professionnels de tout
temps on touche tous était enfant et
qu'il faut laisser le part du rêve à
l'enfant et que là ils jouent à
clairefontaine le lieu magique du
football en france
on peut pas mieux mieux et espérer
qu'elle joue si on les terrains
d'entraînement de l'équipe de france
donc
ensuite on peut pas empêcher de rêver
d'un jour d'être professionnel qu'est le
petit garçon ou la petite fille
maintenant puisque même il ya les
féminines quel enfant et général qui n'a
pas rêvé et des joueurs de foot d'être
un jour un grand joueur ou une grande
joueuse
c'est normal c'est tout à fait tout à
fait l'âge pour ça et je trouve que
c'est chouette c'est chouette de pouvoir
ouvrir les portes justement du du haut
niveau à tous et à 20 pour une petite
part de rêve et puis et puis ben il
rappelé est qui qui partiront au fait
qu'ils sortiront l'actuelle star
montante et mbappé il a été enfin il a
fait des tournois comme ça puisqu'il a
fait un gif sur yvette tournoi
international qui est tous les ans la
voix la fête des mères et il l'a fait ce
tournoi il était depuis les termes comme
tout le monde ils partent tous damas
donc
donc oui un grand oui et un grand bravo
surtout il ya notamment plusieurs
joueurs qui sont passés par la danone
nations cup 1 alexandre lacazette qui
est aujourd'hui arsenal maxwell corner
qui joue à lyon ou encore là mais là qui
est un joueur de tottenham
voilà on ad'autres également moins
connus mais j'ai passé brava non non ce
sont eux les plus connus qui vous a
convaincu
du coup il n vous ayez quoique plus par
jean je rejoinds je rejoins de côté fou
d
1 voilà un terrain qui fait rêver toute
cette dimension là cette motivation
d'avoir pu réaliser ce rêve là et en
même temps je rejoins c'est ce que dit
yann sur tout ce qui est performance
exigences physiques préparation le rêve
il n'est pas
il n'est pas comme on imagine en fait
c'est vrai on athlètes en sportif de
haut niveau c'est il faut quand même
tous les jeunes qui vont vraiment monter
qu'ils vont devenir performant je pense
que il faut qu'il soit aussi préparé
alerter sur ce qu'ils vont rencontrer
sinon on déchante vite et il a des rêves
le ce genre de tournoi et nous organiser
pour dire aux enfants vous allez devenir
professionnel de football à aucun moment
je pense que après on leur donne envie
avec le cas lors de la mise bien sûr
mais dans la vie ce que je disais mais
on leur dit pas où nous l'avons fait sur
la la j'ai une envie c'est de pouvoir
revenir un jour et je la reçois tous de
pouvoir revenir être porté le maillot
des bleus bien sûr c'est magnifique de
pouvoir de pouvoir fouler foulé un
terrain comme ça cela bien sûr mais
c'est vrai qu'on voit là il faut pas
faut pas vendre que du rêve mais je n'ai
aucun indicateur peut dire un enfant
bien sûr que tu te rends compte dans
quelle filière tu t'engages et tout les
problèmes que de contraintes que tu vas
rencontrer non mais laissez moi je dis
pas je dis pas lors leur expliquer tout
mais peut-être simplement leur dire
attention couleurs sphère sportive de
héros c'est très difficile c'est du
boulot mais à 11 ans dit sans avancer
ses idées ses thèmes délicats
c'est quand même délicat moi j'ai mon
fils café du foot pendant deux ans et
heureusement il n'est arrêté ils
arrêtaient de beaucoup trop jeune mais
mais mais quand on voit quand on voit
pourquoi quand on voit certains
dirigeants ça fait peur de valade des
gamins de 5 6 7 ans moi je me disais
mais hey les gars foot c'est un jeu quoi
c'est pas on n'est pas en train de nous
en train de s'amuser un samedi après
midi sur un terrain de foot
elle essaie de s'amuser des gamins on
n'est pas là pour rigoler de sucre en
poudre et le ds que ça développe pas
leur esprit de compétition aussi un toit
comme ça un tournoi comme celui-là
oui mais je pense aussi que c'est une
très bonne opportunité pour les sponsors
danone parce que danone là il fait un
coup d un coup de maître
et en plus il leur octroie 18 depuis 98
au même endroit et donc c'est très
c'est très important mais bon ces gamins
là où c'est vrai il passe une journée
formidable et puis ils sont déçus parce
qu'ils n'ont pas réussi son pari mais au
final puisque 10 l'année prochaine
commencera en niçois après ce qu'il y'a
pas un petit bémol sur cette journée
finalement il n'y avait aucun jour de
l'équipe de france certes il y avait des
installations il n'y avait pas de voir
l'équipe de france parce que c'est un
bémol cela peut-être que pour donner
encore plus envie de devenir footballeur
alors après il ya peut-être des
relations entre danone et la fédération
française de football qui rit qui n'ont
pas été comme elles devraient tous et
pas mais franchement là le parrain de
cette journée c'est blaise matuidi mais
il n'était pas là le jour de l'événement
ça c'est problématique
c'est problématique également genre bah
oui parce que c'est la solution du
gâteau pour les gamins s'il ya plus il
ya un joueur emblématique de la journée
puisque réussi c'est un petit peu
dommage c'est pas un joueur emblématique
qu'il faudrait je pense que sur ce type
d'événement c'est plusieurs et et alors
peut-être pas des joueurs actuels parce
que et les joueurs actifs pascal thurre
nous de faire le procès que bah ils sont
surtout sur des fins de championnat
c'est compliqué de les déplacer
mais par contre des joueurs qui sont qui
viennent d'être en retraite et des gens
des gens qu'on connaît et qu'il gamin
connaissent pas c'est à eux de se
déplacer eux de devenir de venir donner
des conseils et de venir apporter tout
ce qui le tout ce qu'ils savent tous
qu'ils connaissent un thierry henry par
exemple un thierry henry mais bien sûr
mais oueds et des jeunes retraités c'est
à l'autre venir se déplacer sur ce type
d'événement est adonné à l'heure parce
que on leur a donné thierry en plus il
utilise les ulis il vient de la région
quoi donc
en effet ces c il faut leur il faut
redonner ce que le sport vous à sous
leur leur a apporté
on va parler golf maintenant dix minutes
amateurs de golf se sont rendus ce
week-end à mantes-la-jolie la ville a
accueilli du 12 au 14 avril un grand
salon sur la petite balle blanche une
grande première pour la commune le
département des mines qui compte 26 golf
de 18 trous sur son territoire on écoute
le responsable c'est un rendez vous de
passionnés c'est un salon communautaire
autour de la passion golfique c'est à
dire que le but de l'événement c'est
d'immerger les passionnés dans leur
secteur de passion avec toutes les
composantes de la culture golfique avec
du club avec du chaussant de la balle
deux éléments techniques comme été les
maîtres ou les montres connectés qui
permet de géolocaliser connaître la
distance jusqu'au drapeau
au total une centaine d'exposants
étaient présents pendant les trois jours
du salon pour séduire encore plus les
golfeurs des organisateurs ont également
mis en place un practice de 120 mètres
en plein air pour tester le matériel
dans des conditions réelles
c'est un plus parce que les joueurs
veulent essayer les clubs en plein air
ils veulent voir la balle volée ils
veulent voir les performances avec
chaque marque donc c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment très très important mais là ça
sauf pas mal donc on peut se rendre
vraiment compte des trajectoires des
balles et
comment dire des fsi ainsi en effet
s'est vraiment amplifié par justement le
vent une deuxième édition est déjà
programmée pour l'année prochaine à la
mi-avril la question sur ce thème
cet événement peut-il attirer de
nouveaux passionnés
oui ou non non pour yann du guerrier qui
est très très rouge aujourd'hui qu'est
ce que ça peut attirer de nouveaux
passionnés adhérents passionnés un petit
duel entre vous et l'aisne et olivier
ont commencé oui oui
après toute façon tout ce qui est
manifestation agression si on
s'intéresse un peu un sport que c'est
dans sa région que c'est l'occasion
d'aller voir oui je pense que de toute
façon ça peut pas faire de mal au nombre
au nombre d'années ont donc oui après de
là à ce que ce soit réellement des
passionnés des est d'aider des personnes
de haut niveau je sais pas mais oui
après ça peut attirer du monde toute
façon ça peut pas faire de mal vous
terrer oui oui par localisation de tüv
et noir à marcq
bon c'est pas parce que man tu sais pas
c'est peut-être un choix volontaire
d'aidé béret parce que finalement la
population golfique elle est plutôt
autour de versailles est encore beaucoup
beaucoup de progression affaires a gagné
j'ai pas sûr forcément qu'autour de
menthe c'est en terme d' espaces surtout
d'un passager compris notamment au
niveau des parkings de la superficie
finalement c'était compliqué de le faire
ailleurs 40 la jolie d'ailleurs ça ne me
ça veut dire qu'il faut absolument
drainé absolument les gens pour les
faire venir et je pense que il faut
vraiment parce que ce qui est très très
très proche de tout
c'était mantes-la-jolie au moins tout je
ne sais pas mais moi je lui montre la
vie mais je pense qu'il faut absolument
élargir élargir la population kiss kiss
qui veut faire du golf et pour ça c'est
peut-être un choix aussi aussi orienté
parce qu'il faut peut-être aller
chercher des nouveaux golfeurs mais ça
me paraît un peu compliquée dans cette
région dans cette localisation très
précise
donc vous n'êtes pas convaincus non ce
constat que j'ai des gens dont je sais
combien d'années de visiteurs dix mille
visiteurs sur les trois jours
jean - vous n'êtes pas convaincu non je
suis pas convaincu parce que pour moi
cette manifestation ça s'adressait plus
à des golfs déjà que pour faire venir
des nouveaux adhérents dans la mesure où
il y avait c'était la présentation de
matériel
il y avait des zones d'essai avait donc
donc pour moi c'était plus plus adressés
à vraiment des golfeurs cas des nouveaux
il n'y avait pas j'ai pas entendu qu'il
y avait par exemple une zone
d'initiation donc sans nom de la déesse
de test en tout cas la zone de test zone
de test ça veut dire qu'il faut déjà
savoir jouer à aucun moment dans le
reportage d'antenne lui dire qu'il y
avait une zone d'initiation le guide
initiation pour ça veut dire que vous
fermez la porte à ceux qui veulent voir
ce que c'est le golf il ya que des zones
de test deux zones de test si vous avez
déjà joué au golf je ne savais pas faire
un drive c'est pas la peine d'y aller
quoi donc
et puis en plus sur le côté pratique
c'est bien mais c'est un petit peu
éloigné pour aller pour aller à tirer du
monde même s'il ya eu dix mines c'est
bien mais pour attirer de nouveaux
licenciés
c'est parce qu'on fait de mieux à aller
un petit peu excentrés comme ça faire ce
genre de manifestation vient encore une
fois pour moi je dis non simplement
parce que 400 milles en lice anciens du
golf en france et 600000 pratiquant il
ya déjà les gmi non pour les mêmes
raisons que jean et c'est un événement
qui existe depuis plusieurs années mais
qui était qui était sur un an auparavant
au parc floral ou porte de versailles un
truc comme ça et c'est vrai que ça ne
fonctionnait pas du tout et il a été
repris par le nouvel organisateur et ils
étaient délocalisées justement sur
mantes la jolie
ils doivent en faire trois éditions je
crois sur sur l'interview 2 minimum
voilà 2 minimum mais voilà trois
éléments ça devrait c'est devrait
s'établir sur trois voire cinq ans voilà
donc et et l'objectif commencé de
perdurer cet événement pour pour le
rendre incontournable pour pour tous les
golfeurs
je connaissais pas je ne sais pas quels
étaient les objectifs cette année mais
bon donc dix milles s'il parle de sousse
et ben c'est tant mieux pour temps mais
pour eux pour les chiffres sont à temps
d'accord et ben non parfait maintenant
là ou si le golf veut faire b des
nouveaux licenciés
à pour moi la meilleure la meilleure
manière
c'est simplement de faire des portes
ouvertes sur les sur l'égalité sur les
sur les sur les parcours de golf alors
bien sûr que quand on assure une porte
ouverte on ne pourra faire que du du peu
tout alors taper et on ne pourra pas
accéder directement sur grand terrain
mais voilà c'est après lisez c'est de
justement apporter le golf dans d'autres
endroits
ils n'ont pas l'habitude de voir du
golfe un pouvoir pour pouvoir aller
assez assez à ce type de salon
ce sont des personnes averties qui est
parce que je suis désolé vous venez d si
vous voulez discuter avec un avec un
vendeur vous lui dites vous n'avez pas
le discours vous n'avez pas le web et
donc c'est très très compliqué je pense
que vous faut d'abord venir goûter
commencer à appréhender la chose avant
de avant d'aller voir un avant d'aller
voir un marchand de marchands de
matériel pour lui demander quelles sont
les différences que vous pouvez avoir
par rapport à essentiellement un salon
pour vendre du matériel ancien c'est un
centre occitan absalon qui était pour
les fours les golfeurs et donc non pas
pour faire découvrir la pratique du golf
est ce qu'on n'aurait pas mieux fait de
l'organiser au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
olivier g prêt à accueillir la ryder cup
sur fait parce que c'est essentiel c'est
sûr c'est de pouvoir faire venir faire
des opérations portes ouvertes utiliser
les practice pour faire venir les
enfants et les faire découvrir en même
temps mais le paysage parce que des
paysages en lui-même du golfe et
magnifique surtout et puis en plus après
la ryder cup sera est certain a manqué
une bonne idée mais je pense que
commercialement s'était promise à viable
pour pouvoir accueillir sur trois jours
le bon ça veut dire que certains dont
5000 personnes le dimanche au pouvoir
les accueillir et maîtres les bagnoles
etc c'est pas les casseurs fait sur un
maul la vente
non non ils ont craint ce volet un
fictif pour
en soi le clé puisque j'avais des
espaces de practice donc ils ont créé
près on va passer maintenant notre
rubrique débats dans notre débat nous
allons parler de l'arbitrage un centre
national pourrait ouvrir à poissy d'ici
fin 2021 quelques pas du succès futur
centre d'entraînement du psg initiative
a été proposée par la communauté urbaine
grand paris seine et oise et la
municipalité on écoute justement le
maire de poissy au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude on parle pas
seulement de ce qui est le plus
emblématique entre guillemets le
football de tous les arbitres le
handball le basket le judo tous les
arbitres de france vont pouvoir élire
domicile ici sur le territoire dans un
centre national de l'arbitrage on
viendra parler évidemment de leur
expertise
murray aurait également les efforts mais
on verra également les suivre du point
de vue médical
le site pourrait également servir de
préparation pour les volontaires des
jeux olympiques de 2024
la question sur ce thème est ce qu'on a
vraiment besoin d'un centre national de
l'arbitrage
oui ou non est ce qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'un centre national de
l'arbitrage
non pour genre de partage et on va faire
un petit duel entre jean et ian encore
le retour genre a été le premier à
prendre votre petite raquette cheminots
pourquoi alors j aime découvrir là que
c'est
un centre d'arbitrage multi multi sports
multisports voilà multidisciplines pas
seulement pour le pauvre be pour la
logistique avec eux
la plupart des disciplines on a déjà des
comme le foot le rugby par exemple
c'était que de clairefontaine et est le
marcoussis merci yann et marcoussis
elle marque aussi il est sur le rugby
c'est une première gdc rêver c'est la
fatigue essentiellement donc on a déjà
des centres dédiés où les arbitres
peuvent et le sont d'ailleurs ils y vont
se former se suivre des stages ceux là
monter un centre rien que pour les
arbitres omnisports je ne vois pas la
finalité je vois pas comment on pourra
toutes les disciplines est ce que ça
fait du général ce qu'on va travailler
sur le physique le mental le
l'appréhension afin montet toutain tout
un système pour rien que pour ça moi ça
me paraissait sans pareil inutile dans
la mesure où chaque fédération
ben peut le faire individuellement dans
leur coin avec leur centre aussi
performante qu'il le soit bien désiriez
moi je suis assez je suis à sucre
hautement pour maintenant je le vois pas
comme dit comme dit jean je le vois pas
pour les disciplines football rugby qui
ont déjà leur l'or
leur centre à droite et à gauche et qui
ont de la puissance de pouvoir le toit
l'idée c'est de les jours regroupés en
un centre mais moi je me mets alors et
ben pourquoi pourquoi pas parce que
quand on à l'université on va
l'université et tout le monde ne prend
pas les mêmes disciplines et pourtant on
va tous au même endroit donc important
d'apprendre des choses diverses et
variées donc pourquoi pas l'arbitrage
l'apprendre au même endroit et après
pouvoir le dire démultiplier sur divers
divers oui on est on est bien d'accord
mais par contre quand même des
passerelles commune entre tous les 1
entre toutes les entrées tout les entre
tous les sports et donc du coup c'est
peut-être là dessus qu'il ya quelque
chose à jouer
après les spécificités de chaque sport
bien sûr qu'il faudrait travailler il
faudrait travailler tout pour pour tout
le monde là où là où moi je vois je vois
aussi de l'intérêt c'est pour les plus
petits sports qui n'ont pas les moyens
de pouvoir former leur propre arbitre
est aujourd'hui l'eau par exemple
comment vous pensé au judo danse au vélo
alors je pense au vélo et quand ça a
failli commencé qu'au vélo bien sûr mais
non je pense au vélo je pense à de sport
que j'ai pratiqué le cyclisme et le
roller ou en effet l'arbitrage dans leur
l'art est très très important et on n'a
pas tous les détails et donc donc voilà
je pense que pour ces sports un petit
peu plus discret et bien cette cette
structure pour aller pourra les aider
les accompagner
et alors je parle même pas les arbitres
de pétanque qui eux ont une vraie vraie
havrais besoin sur sur l'arbitrage
c'était prévu jack mais mais mais non
voilà way dont je moi j'y vois un gros
intérêt
et je pense que c'est très important
surtout aujourd'hui où alors dans le
football on parle de lavaré il faut et
qui assez il devrait y avoir un
normalement une salle dédiée justement
la vidéo voilà mes bien chers et ce à
toutes les fédérations ne peuvent pas la
portée alors à leurs arbitres les
arbitres de tennis par exemple aussi
tout simplement tu es un sport dont on
n'a pas du tout parlé sa carabine au
tennis juge de ligne ça demande quand
même des des qualités particulières
alors la fédération de france de tennis
a certainement aussi c'est déjà déjà ce
sont son modèle de formation
mais voilà peut-être s'appuyer sur
l'expérience d'autres sports pour
pouvoir la mener sur les uns les autres
voilà moi je dis non c'est parce que
trop diversité olivier est une structure
qui s'ajoute à une autre qui est déjà à
l'aise ce qui marche qui marche
oui puisque finalement on le voit bien
les arbitres en tout cas vendredi ils
ont tous les ans les départements tous
les tous les mois elle tournait réunion
ensuite il monte au niveau régional la
ligue et ensuite ils ont aussi d'autres
d'autres d'autres organisations qui sont
mises en place mais en plus donc s'il
fallait en plus aller dans un centre
national pour débattre oui débattent de
succès c'est gigantesque pour le contenu
quels contenus exactement alors pour
l'instant on n'a pas comme je disais un
toutes les lignes vraiment sûr sur ce
projet mais l'idée ça serait d'avoir un
pôle santé vraiment par rapport à la
santé dans l'arbitrage c'est à dire
comment gérer ses efforts par exemple il
y aurait une autre
notre pièce on va dire qui pourrait
parler de la vidéo une autre qui
pourrait parler des des règles comment
gérer les situations un peu de crise
ou alors ça c'est la vie c'est
complètement différent
un arbitre de tennis qui est sur la
chaise lui ce match de rugby ou de
football qui court qui fait des
kilomètres pellicule reste un match il a
fixé sa division sera discuté le câble
c'est bon et le monde ont un intérêt qui
est beaucoup plus petit et on a animé
deux arbitres parce que tu parles c'est
ici où là je vois je vois pas l'harmonie
c'est pour ça c'est tellement diverse
c'est le temps que le débat est trop tôt
de l'avancée du projet pour qu'on puisse
en parler
hélène est ce que vous êtes plutôt
d'accord avec ce projet est mitigé mais
à moins de wii / sport et de mettre des
commandes y regarder cette vidéo des
infrastructures particulières en
fonction de certains sports etc et de
regrouper au même endroit
plusieurs spécificités ou plusieurs
composantes d'arbitrage oui maintenant
j'ai un peu l'impression c'est moi mais
j'ai un peu l'impression que c'est
beaucoup d'argent et beaucoup de mousse
beaucoup pour un truc et ouais il est
sûrement trop tôt pour an pour discuter
de ça parce que c'est ça qui en première
mondiale ça n'a jamais été vues de
complicité d'autres locations dans son
quartier se sentent bien et est bien on
pourrait le destiner aux spectateurs
pour l'éducation des spectateurs et à ce
moment là à l'endroit où pourrait
regrouper certaines disciplines pour
pouvoir essayer d'inculquer des
nouvelles malheur aux spectateurs pour
leur faire contre supporters mais pour
l'instant tout fait en france tous
sports confondus il y à 246 milles
arbitres et 3 2 millions de bénévoles
qui tourne autour d'un arbitrage vois la
magnifique et du coup y aurait
normalement une émulation pour aller
justement dans ce centre qui seraient
perdus vous comme on disait le
clairefontaine de l'arbitrage
m je pense que c'est aussi une histoire
de brasser un peu d'argent j'ai un peu
l'impression que ça peut être ça et
parce que j'imagine bien que personne
n'aille aller gratuitement travail son
arbitrage
franchement j'attends de voir le projet
un peu
un peu plus évoluée déjà pour voir
comment ils vont ils vont représenter le
découper organisé parce que ça peut
peut-être également mutualiser les
installations aussi en sachant qu'il y a
également le centre d'entraînement du
psg qui sera juste juste à côté à
quelques mètres enfin moi je pense que
c'est pas ce genre de chose s'est passé
pas de dédiant c'est pas du tout du tout
du tout approprié pour football ou le
rugby c'est parce que ils ont déjà leur
propre structure que c'est déjà une
machine qui est qui et qui est déjà en
route pour moi c'est vraiment plus pour
des sports pour des sports annexes et
des sports qui n'ont pas les moyens de
le faire si l'objectif c'est de faire un
truc doublon avec leurs fontaines ou
avec avec marcoussis tout faux et
uniformiser oscillé toute la capacité
d'arbitrage et toutes les
en foot rugby on imagine bien que même
en gym etc
on imagine bien que c'est très cadré
très très très organisée par contre en
effet tout ce qui est roller ou d'autres
sports comme ça le quidditch dans
plaisante je me doute bien qu'il faut
peut-être un peu cadré justement
uniformiser tout ça pour éviter que
chacun y aille un petit peu avec ces sa
sauce et ses petites adaptations
personnes tous les samedis à vous vous
avez demandé de quidditch on va en
parler
hélène un ajustement belle transition on
va s'intéresser donc un sport insolite
le quidditch réalisés précédemment sa
discipline a été créé en 2005 elle est
dérivée du sport fictif de la saga harry
potter
aujourd'hui des compétitions sont
organisées partout en france et dans le
monde le samedi 20 avril et qui souvent
entend réaliser une coupe de la ligue
présentation de ce sport au micro de
mélanie peau qui au lieu de ça soit 1
soit enfin parlons avec des trous pour
pouvoir me remettre la main mais non
c'est un ballon de volley dégonfler les
cogneurs ces débats non 2 ball qui sont
légèrement dégonflé qu'on peut dire à
une main si le vif d'or mais c'est
quelqu'un dit on joue avec une balle de
tennis au niveau des fesses
donc voilà je viens on a gardé on a
essayé d'adapter pour des mots lyon
n'est pas magicien donc on continue à
ont fait avec les moyens du bord comme
on est comme étant moldus moi j'ai
toujours pas reçu ma carte de poudlard
je sais pas si oui mais moi n'auront
genre je vous amuser je ne lis pas
c'est-à-dire potter donc j'ai du mal à
jouer vous pouvez voir les films alors
deux équipes je rappelle les règles deux
équipes de sept joueurs jouent donc sur
des faux balaie le terrain et au ballet
mesure 55 mètres par 33 m il ya donc
trois anneaux disposé à des hauteurs
différentes faisant référence à des buts
on les voit justement à l'image le but
est de marquer plus de points que
l'adversaire est à chaque fois qu'on
marque on marque 10 points un match dure
entre 20 et 30 minutes et à la fin il
faut attraper le vif d'or qui apparaît
la 17e minute de jeu voilà on le voit le
vif d'or
il ne peut être attrapé que par un seul
[Rires]
sur sur dans l'interview
oui oui voilà sur le vif d'or voilà
c'est une balle de tennis coller aux
fesses de quelqu'un qui court mais moi
j'ai envie de pleurer mais je sais pas
même pas d'horizon et je sais pas quoi
penser
alors c'est très bien jean ah ouais non
franchement pense pour s'amuser si on
fait un pique nique sous sas et c'est
sympa franchement c'est sympa mais bien
trop compliqué à mettre en place pour
pique-niquer avec les balais avec des
cerceaux et a raison il faut être qui on
doit pas de rosé avec modération
évidemment non mais oui je alors la
question sur ce thème ce sport peut-il
percer en france non ans maintenant là
c'est pas possible non ah non on va on
va laisser parler tout simplement
olivier parce que il est quand même
mitigé quand même sur connaissez pas ce
mot je connaissais pas ce sport donc
j'ai regardé wilkipédia évidemment
surtout ce matin il ya un stage de rugby
et des enfants pour schouten versailles
il y avait trente gamins donc je les ai
réunis je leur ai posé la question
qu'est ce que vous savez ceux qui ne
savent pas ce que c'est que ce fameux
supporte le préfet dit le mélomane une
a3 qu'on avait la main ça veut dire que
trois sur 30 90 % des enfants que
j'étais là je serais posé des questions
après sur le quidditch qui m'ont répondu
harry potter les balles elle a donc
finalement moi je suis complètement du
coup la dent il soit pas le seul
d'ailleurs je comprends mais si cette
génération là qu'est la génération qui
est la petite génération des enfants
d'aujourd'hui
siph quelques aussi quelque part on
arrive à animer alors foule animée parce
que harry potter est ce que c'est
continuer à animer je ne sais pas mais à
peut-être quelque chose rare aujourd'hui
400 licenciés 1 grosso modo de la
fédération française de 400 oui
quarante équipes en france
ouais alors actuellement la question
qu'on leur a posé ce que vous pensez que
ça peut devenir un sport olympique a
donc ils ont répondu peut-être un sport
de démonstration voilà l'incroyable en
activité en activité oui c'est très
sympa ça permet de 2 comment dire de
deschamps j'ai participé voilà une
activité un peu sportive de laon faire
vraiment des matches
enfin vraiment un vrai sport avec de
vraies compétitions je pense que ça peut
devenir intéressant
le jour où chacun aura un vrai ballet
qui lui permettra de voler et où la
balle jaune à elle ne sera plus derrière
mais y aura un mec qui va la
télécommande et et là je commence à
avoir un peu de voiliers type les matchs
de robots et les matchs de robots la
tisseuse non non je pense que parce que
le ballet est drôle doublé dire non les
matchs de robots là où ils sont dans
l'arène et puis il ya les mecs qu'il est
con et pis un peu de succès
voilà bon bah il faudrait qu'il ya un
mec qui pilotent justement cette petite
balle là qui va à droite avec un type
type de rhône avec la vie commence pour
guider les balaie également évident
après le bal et le ballet où les pilotes
à la haine
voilà je pense que en effet il peut y
avoir un vrai attrait mais il faut que
la mécanique s'y mettent et donc il en
faut beaucoup plus de moyens
parce que pour l'instant à courir avec
leur balle entre les jambes
ils sont un peu ridicules enfin tout
travail ou là ils sont si je trouve que
l'idée mais c'est vrai que s'ils veulent
être dans cet esprit développer vraiment
l'esprit du quidditch et c'est harry
potter et c'est chez caroline et tout ça
et je pense que voilà il leur faudrait
peut-être un peu plus de moyens pour là
je vois je vois grosse outre la laddh à
elle elle sert les jambes elle a les
deux mains libres pour attraper le
ballon je je sais pas concevable c'est
la sienne balèti l albanais normalement
il ya un moment où quand elle conduit eh
ben elle pourra pas se permettre de
nouvelles réglementations de la rake fin
de la fiction quand on joue enfin moi si
jamais demain je vais jouer au football
je joue au football comme les pros sur
tous les produits donc voilà si je fais
un truc je le fais à fond si tu ne l'as
jamais les mains son guidon belle
toujours pis non non pas sur piste à ces
jus des boules bâton c'est ça n'est pas
les déballer dior à poil dur s'aggrave
alors est ce que ça vous donne envie
d'essayer vous non mais c'est quand même
assez sérieux quand même les règles ont
été établies en 2005 quand même ça fait
quand même nom met de temps que c'est on
a le nom structurelle du tracas celle
qui a fait les règles en la matière qui
démentent et on l'a pas les américains
je crois des américains bon comme quoi
ils font pas quand même que du bien mais
non franchement beau aussi c'est ce
discours ils font du sport il couvre
tous ceux des peines ses biens après une
chute au covial j'ai un petit peu
ridicule et le match donne par exemple
jean paul jaud cherche des volontaires
pour faire déjà peur qu'un champ pour
autre chose que la mono machel
la petite ouais ça fait cas mais non
mais non mais c'est vrai par contre il
devrait pas il devrait pas lâcher le
manche
il doit y avoir que nous mais où il
pourrait jouer avec la déjà la règle
alors marc modifie le règlement nous
déjà voilà et le match à paris on ne
mettrait pas comme ça mais bon faut pas
non plus trop dans les détails ce qui me
gêne je pense avoir déjà 30 ans 40 ans
qui sont en train de courir sur rise ont
une moyenne d'âge d'environ 25-30 ans et
ouais mais ça ne s'est satisfait mais je
pense que c'est ça qui est défectueux
jeunes ont quand même et également dans
la plupart des clubs
paris arrive en juin quand il a 12 ans
quand même ouais ouais la première fois
dit comme quoi vous nommez d'imaginer
déjà le cas mais toi tu vas jouer au fou
dj tu vas venir
alors on parle également de de
similitudes avec le rugby olivier ce que
vous la voyez cette similitude avec le
rugby rugby avec le foulard dans le dos
peut-être enfin au niveau des contacts
donc je sais pas mais franchement à part
le fly de l'atria mi temps peut-être
troisième mi-temps voit plus la
troisième mi temps
le bal est là oui c'est ça prenez mi
temps avec le ballet on peut les
et quand ils se tapent beau de les voir
kalou des anecdotes n'a pas demandé en
tout cas
alors en 2012 il ya quand même eu le
premier tournoi inter continental 1 au
royaume uni à oxford qui s'est déroulée
la france avait terminé 2e comme quoi
sur trois fans des gens qui aient envie
de s'amuser et qu'ils le font à fond et
évidemment que voilà n'importe quelle
personne qu'un peu passionné par une
discipline va se donner à fond sur un
match ça m'étonnerait même pas 500
m'étonne pas qu'on aura une deuxième
chance après la ja pas 400 licenciés on
a 400 ans vient en fait de deux
d'inscrire gens pour qu'ils infiltrent
les licenciés qui nous fasse des compte
tenu du rejet faire la main le mec a un
beau gabarit 1 face à un défenseur
je pense enfin de prendre et la france a
remporté également trois médailles d'or
lors des coupes d'europe ont comme coma
comme quoi il y avait du bruit leach
comme tweetdeck williams 6-2 par contre
pour le développement de pays 32 jours
de terre aux états unis il ya beaucoup
de beaucoup plus et qu'il a beaucoup
plus de lecteurs pardon excusez moi donc
pour l'instant non vous ne validez pas
autour de cette table toujours je pense
qu'on en parle 1 mickaël du club de
ligue 1 et paris est très long et très
content je souhaitais c'était un match à
viroflay
c'est ça c'est à dire que c'est parce
que je pense à vivre avec elle pendant
quand même pas vous avez une pâte de
bois
mais je participe aux éditions et je
retiens celles auxquelles je participe
voilà on devrait essayer de paris je
vais essayer le quidditch
comme j'aurai comme je ferais filmer ou
mauvais film et vous souhaitez si vous
voulez gens en les servant sans voilà
enfin comme le quidditch vivent dans
mercier c'est la fin de cette émission
on va terminer par une citation de la
superstar du football cristiano ronaldo
5 fois ballon d'or c'est en ajoutant une
bonne éthique de travail au talent qu'on
devient un grand joueur je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 68
[Musique]